for the white house is on the
candidate's clashing with just
50 days to go president trump and joe
biden chipping away at each other as a
new
fox news poll shows it's just a five
point race with trump
closing the gap both trump and biden
campaigning today
the president on his way to arizona
after visiting california
and detour into joe biden during a rally
in nevada last night
at no time before has there been a
clearer choice between two parties two
visions two philosophies two agendas
for the future joe biden spent the last
47 years selling out america look at
what he's done
everything he's done was wrong he always
voted the wrong way
even his secretary of defense as
secretary of state
they said he always voted the wrong way
meanwhile joe biden leaving the comforts
of his couch to push his progressive
agenda
and attack president trump over climate
change
if you give a climate arsonist four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised if we have
more america blaze
if you give a climate denier four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised when more
of america
is underwater and speaking of
progressives socialist bernie sanders is
warning democrats
that the election won't be a slam dunk
for biden bernie also offering up this
advice
i think biden is in an excellent
position to win this election
uh but i think we've got to do more
as a campaign than just uh go after
trump trump is a disaster i think most
people know it
but we also have to give people a reason
to vote
for joe biden i guess bernie sanders was
deep in the vermont woods there
okay uh juan williams
[Laughter]
i mean honestly it looks like biden took
the weekend off
he didn't campaign anywhere today he
goes to his home state and reads a
speech
president trump was in nevada all
weekend now he's in california today and
he's going to arizona later
without pointing to the polls juan
because we know the polls can be tricky
how is this strategy going to work for
joe going forward
well it's worked for him so far jesse
and the question is as you put it
what does joe biden do in the last 50
days of this race
and so far it looks like things are
breaking for him
if you look at you know the money game
he had a record amount of money raised
in august and now
it looks like president trump is facing
a money crunch so
the advertising right now strongly
favors joe biden
especially in those swing states and
then the second thing to say is that
mike bloomberg the former mayor of new
york who ran in the democratic primary
just put a 100 million dollars
into one swing state florida so that's a
big boost to the biden campaign
at this juncture because as you may know
biden is struggling right now with the
latino vote
and so here comes bloomberg with a big
boost in that regard
and i think you also have to keep in
mind that right now
a lot of the news cycle has really not
been favorable to president trump
obviously the wildfires out west right
but the wildfires aren't anybody's
wait has it ever been favorable news
i'm just saying jesse that right now
given that given the uh
bob woodward book on especially on the
coronavirus
uh there are lots of things that just
aren't breaking the president's way
all right well i would say on the money
thing bloomberg spent a lot of money on
running for president and
that didn't really work out for him and
trump still has the money advantage
dana juan brings up uh joe biden
struggling with hispanics
in florida i mean you've seen a lot of
media ring the alarm over the weekend
about that
um you know if trump does better than he
did in 2016 with hispanics
that could be a big difference
well i think i don't know i don't know
what's going to happen but
i would not at all be surprised if he
does better with
hispanics this time around keep in mind
one you have
hispanics are not just like gonna vote
just as a block there's lots of
different types of hispanics plus you
have
a difference in youthful hispanics that
tend to really love bernie sanders
and then you have some older hispanics
who like love the
economics that the president trump came
in with
and also might be concerned with law and
order issues
um so there's a there's a lot of
different things happening there i also
think that the hispanic
vote might be a reason that you saw
president trump go to nevada that's a
state that
i think that he would love to pick up
it's only six electoral college votes
but i think that the trump campaign is
saying why not try
at this point and you know when it comes
to bloomberg if he's going to put 100
million dollars into florida
you would think that he might want to
try to focus on seniors because
president trump
is not doing as well with seniors in
florida as he did at this
point in 2016. um but i also don't think
that
paid advertising is going to be enough
president trump showed that you could
win in 2016 and not have
as much money yeah as before so i don't
necessarily think that that's that and i
just the difference in these campaigns
i'm trying to understand
and maybe they're right maybe biden's
team says our internals show that we can
just sit here
on this lead we don't have to do much
you know we don't have to go out there
we don't have to try to win the news
cycles
because even though president trump
might have some negative articles here
and there
the visuals are he is out and about he
is there in california he's meeting with
the governor
he had the governor of the opposing
party today thanking him
praising him and right before an
election
when did that happen before oh hurricane
sandy do you remember
when barack obama came to new jersey and
he got the hug from chris christie and
republicans were so mad
but this is what you do when you are the
president of the united states and
you're going to help a state
that is in desperate need of help and
that's what you have in california right
now
yeah and i guess joe biden was talking
about climate change today degen
giving a speech out in the middle of
nowhere with no one watching
the president though is kind of shifting
into a higher gear now he has a huge ad
buy
fox news just announced it's going to be
all about the economy
he's moving from law and order to the
economy the number one issue for voters
in the fall and he's going to be
spending well over 10 million dollars to
make the case
how do you see that playing out well and
he already and paul after poll even the
new fox news poll
we weren't going to talk about him but
he wins on the economy that is his
strong suit he needs to convert voters
from say worrying about the coronavirus
to worrying about the economic recovery
i just want to know what bernie sanders
is up to
because he seems like he is with with
this rhetoric there was the story in the
washington post about him
kind of being critical of the biden
campaign he seems like he is
this close to doing a big belly flop
right into the biden campaign in a way
that is not helpful and i'll point to
see the green agenda
joe biden soft peddling it today talking
about a renaissance in
manufacturing and agriculture well
is bernie sanders going to come out and
say hey we're getting rid of fossil
fuels and power production in 15 years
and we're going to
kill jobs in ohio and pennsylvania oh
and your electricity prices are going to
go up
or is he going to remind people say the
elderly voters who favor joe biden by
nine percentage points right now over
trump
that he would that sanders was in favor
of
get rid of medicare as we know it and
outlawing
private health insurance i'll just raise
this issue biden does not need the mr
green genes from
vermont reminding people that biden
could be the most progressive president
since fdr
because again that's the fear that
bernie sanders is the ventriloquist
and joe biden is well the dummy yeah
greg what do you make about the
emergence of bernie
at this stage that's not the story
i can't believe we haven't even it's
we're nine minutes in and we haven't
talked about the fact
that joe rogan has offered to moderate a
four-hour debate
and trump has already accepted it uh joe
biden was super excited about it except
he thought it was rogaine and not rogan
but i think it's a great idea and i i
guarantee you joe doesn't even
biden doesn't even know who joe rogan is
and it would be something
very very very valuable for our country
to have a four-hour
debate between those two guys but
somebody's got to tell joe
that he shouldn't blame problems that
existed
when he was in power and he had done
nothing to solve them
you know it's like blaming calling trump
a climate arsonist
is so desperate that's like me blaming
dana
for the grades i had in college or
blaming
jesse for that one arrest in 1992. i
didn't even know
jesse back then so he's now he's like
he's blaming
trump for what forest management because
that's the problem in california
it's not climate change it's forest
management it's not
reducing the dry fuel and creating like
lanes to get in there to fight the fires
but that i don't want to get in the
weeds in that one i'm going to make my
daily plea
that we know with 50 days there's going
to be 50 bombshells i would argue with
with juan that bob woodward's bombshell
lasted approximately 30 minutes
i mean it just disappeared so that means
that they're gonna have to keep
recycling them
coming up with new ones and new ones and
social media and media is gonna figure
out ways to manipulate these stories
none of them are gonna be true
they're all gonna be based on private
conversations which can be interpreted
at their
worst and taken out of context that's
the three step to a bombshell
okay you have private conversation taken
out of context
what was the third part uh interpreted
at their worst
that is every single definition of a
bombshell
and they're going to do this every
single day and it's going to be
manipulated but
especially by twitter and google so be
prepared that they're going to try to
get us
at our throats and we have to resist it
right
and us on the phone what about what
about when it's on tape greg it's on
tape you can't you can't
say yes he didn't really mean that i
actually saw him
say it to jim because i heard it that's
why it wasn't a bombshell
it happened on television right so i'm
saying that's a bombshell
when the guy is there on tape you have a
lot below
no problem we have it under control oh
my gosh
oh my god that's sarcasm is not a fact
juan but good luck
all right you two try to be nice